Wouldn't it be great to live in the world
of Star Wars?
Oh, sure, you might have to deal with random
incursions on your home planet by jerks in
fancy helmets.
You might run afoul of some rough and tumble
characters at your local cantina — or you
might be one of those characters, and end
up getting your arm sliced off by an old British
dude with a lightsaber.
All kinds of crazy things might happen in
that world, but hey, crazy things happen in
our real world, too.
It'd mostly be a hoot — unless, of course,
you end up working for the Empire.
If you think your boss is always on your back
or intrudes too heavily upon your privacy,
just wait until you hear about the working
conditions of your average Imperial Stormtrooper
— and in particular, what really goes on
inside those helmets.
Before we get into all of that, though, we
should get this out of the way: not just anybody
can fill out an application, undergo a background
check, and put on that iconic white armor,
all set for their first day of trying and
failing to shoot rebel soldiers.
In the early days of the Empire, Stormtroopers
were recruited exclusively from the ranks
of the clones being produced on the planet
Kamino, an operation that was once overseen
by the deadly mercenary Jango Fett.
This is why, in many of their cinematic appearances,
Stormtroopers all sound the same, are all
the same height, and are all left-handed.
As time went on and the cloning operation
was eventually shuttered, the Empire began
to recruit Stormtroopers from its human population
— but they had to be rigorously tested for
absolute loyalty.
They also presumably had to demonstrate with
their blaster rifles that they couldn't hit
the broad side of a barn.
Once they were deemed compliant and loyal,
Stormtroopers were totally trusted to carry
out their orders and faithfully represent
the Empire without supervision.
Or… scratch that.
That's a lie.
Actually, it was kind of the exact opposite
of that.
Stormtroopers were required to stay in uniform
basically at all times while they were on
duty — which isn't fun, but also isn't the
bad part.
While they were putting in the work for their
hard earned credits, they were also being
watched.
In each Stormtrooper's helmet was a comm device
which broadcast everything that they said,
all the time, to the Empire — where it was
monitored and recorded.
It was basically like being the target of
a super high-tech surveillance program, broadcasting
from your face, and always listening.
These guys were getting eavesdropped on by
the boss every minute of every shift.
This served two main purposes: ensuring they
remained productive and squelching potentially
rebellious speech.
Now, to be sure, Stormtroopers' armor and
helmets had some pretty sweet features as
well.
They were designed to dissipate energy, and
the helmets provided filtered air and an awesome
heads-up display, which compensated for their
limited field of vision — but apparently
did nothing to help them fire their blasters
more accurately.
The fact that Stormtroopers' speech was constantly
monitored raises an interesting certainty:
there were millions of those guys, and somebody
had to be doing all of the monitoring.
Perhaps this was done by specially programmed
droids, but we like to think that somewhere,
on some planet, was what basically amounted
to the biggest call center you've ever seen,
with cubicles stretching as far as the eye
can see.
In each cubicle sat a loyal but underpaid
minion of the Empire, grinding through the
daily slog of poring over the audio records
of whatever Stormtrooper they'd been assigned
to.
In the break room, they would boast to their
co-workers about how loyal and professional
"their guy" was.
They'd make excuses for his poor marksmanship,
whispering under their breath that those heads-up
displays were made by some shady manufacturer
on the Outer Rim.
And when "their guy" inevitably got blasted
into oblivion or carved up by a Jedi Knight,
they'd be allowed to take five and solemnly
reflect on his sacrifice while listening to
the Imperial March.
Maybe living in the world of Star Wars wouldn't
be so awesome, after all.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about Star Wars
are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.